des gestes d'une grande délicatesse pour
enlever les crimes du café ses mains
sont celles d'un buteur international il
est japonais son travail ont recherché
les meilleurs cafés dans le monde pour
sa société
ce sont ces grains qui ont poussé dans
les hauteurs de martinique horrifié par
les japonais et surtout comparé cet
après midi à tartane au meilleur café du
monde éthiopien one des kenyans hawaïens
et attention le nôtre serait parmi les
meilleurs du monde du très haut de gamme
une aventure qui a des luttes il y a
deux ans nous sommes dans les hauteurs
du nord de la martinique ces plants de
café sont les bébés d'un pied retrouvé
chez un planteur son adn est le même que
ceux qui poussent en ethiopie ces plans
que vous voyez sont donc exceptionnel
ils ont été reproduits en martinique à
plus de vingt mille arbres et
aujourd'hui ils produisent du café prêt
à être dégusté ce qu'a fait les
premières cerises ont été récoltés elles
sont venues à tartane parce qu'à une
torréfaction qui est fait ici les
premières tours et factions nous a
permis d'avoir déjà dans la salle des
parfums sectionnelles qui est le parfum
de l'arabica tipica qui provient de
martinique
mais pourquoi les japonais sont ils
intéressés par d'autres cafés
il y a plus de dix ans il était déjà
venu
claude lise président du conseil général
leur avait offert un plan mais pourquoi
notre café est il exceptionnel parce
qu'il est arrivée en martinique en 1720
louis xiv en personne avait chargé l'un
de ses officiers un dénommé deux clics
de le convoyer en martinique ce plan
venait d'ethiopie via les pays arabes
via la hollande ça c'est l'histoire
officielle
mais l'histoire officieuse raconte que
des arbres ont été volés en ethiopie par
des pirates français sur un ordre
officiel et qu'ils ont été plantés en
martinique
nous sommes sur la bonne voie nous avons
un café qui est excellent donc comme si
une culture de niche petites quantités
donc c'est une culture à haute valeur
ajoutée c'est ce qu'on veut puisque le
café quo actuel du café chez 3 euros on
pense souvent de ce café au delà de 30
euros le kilo vous avez bien entendu ce
café sera vendu plus de 30 euros le kilo
toute la première récolte est déjà
vendue à des japonais
le lancement de notre café plantés par
des petits producteurs martiniquais se
fera en juillet 2020 au japon pour les
jeux olympiques